we welcome you back to CBS mornings
we've got big big breaking news right
now so let's bring in all of our local
stations for this special report
this is a CBS News special report I'm
Gail King with Tony decopal and Nate
Burleson we are here in New York and the
White House has just confirmed that the
United States and Russia have agreed
have agreed to a prisoner swap to free
basketball star Brittany Greiner very
big news indeed the two-time Olympic
gold medalist for Team USA was released
just minutes ago in exchange for a
convicted Russian arms dealer Victor
boot known as the man who makes War
possible he was serving a 25-year
sentence in the U.S for conspiring to
kill Americans and conspiring to sell
weapons to a terrorist organization and
if you don't remember what happened
Greiner was detained in Russia in
February after airport security found
Vape canisters containing cannabis oil
in her luggage in August she was
sentenced to nine years in prison for
drug possession and smuggling we'll Face
the Nation moderator and chief Foreign
Affairs correspondent that's Margaret
Brennan is with us now from Washington
Margaret this is so exciting and such
welcome news what can you tell us about
this exchange it absolutely is Gail and
this is a big deal for the Biden
Administration the U.S official has
confirmed the transfer has taken place
this morning just within the past few
moments Brittany Greiner was transferred
into U.S custody now the prisoner swap
took place on an airport tarmac in the
United Arab Emirates that was the
agreed-upon neutral point for U.S
government plane carrying arms dealer
Victor boot to meet up with a Russian
aircraft carrying the 32 year old
American basketball star President Biden
authorized this swap just last week
greiner's first action we expect after
these nine months of imprisonment will
be to soon undergo a medical evaluation
this is standard operating procedure
this is something that is expected to
occur at a U.S military base and she
will have to clear that before returning
to the United States
Margaret you know everybody wants to
know how soon can she be back on U.S
soil well that medical evaluation has to
to First Take play scale and I want to
point out here that the very fact that
the transfer happened at all is huge
because the diplomacy had been stalled
for so long and it all came together
just within the past few weeks now this
is a one for one swap the reason that is
important is because the Biden
Administration has been trying for
months to get out to Americans Brittany
Greiner and Paul Whalen he is a U.S
marine veteran who has been behind bars
since 2018. at this hour CBS is
reporting that it is just a one-for-one
swap that Paul Whalen remains in Russian
custody at the moment but Brittany
Greiner is now in the hands of U.S
officials
with U.S custody no longer Behind Bars
no longer in Russia now in the United
Arab Emirates so this is a a big
breakthrough for the administration and
we'll be getting further details and
Report morning gal I just want to make
this point here to you because I think
it's important disclosure to our viewers
CBS first learned that this swap was
going to happen last Thursday and CBS
News agreed that the grinder for about
swap which we knew was underway that we
would not report on the details of it
this was at the request of the White
House which asked us not to make it
public because officials expressed grave
concern about the fragility of the
emerging deal and feared it would impede
the safety perhaps even put those
Americans at risk and so we are bringing
this news to you first this morning Gail
and it is certainly good news for the
Griner family
it is so exciting and of course we kept
our word on that of course
we've known about it for some time just
to see it happen and come about Margaret
I can't tell you how excited everybody
is that was pulling from Brittany Griner
this is such great news thank you
Margaret that's right Margaret we'll
check back in with you a little bit
later and yes CBS did hold up our end of
the bargain speaking of that bargain uh
we do expect to hear from President
Biden real soon chief White House
correspondent Nancy Cordes joins us
right now Nancy good morning what are we
hearing good morning Nate we have some
new information we were told by a U.S
official a short time ago that the
president this morning spoke by phone
with Brittany Greiner herself and with
her wife shirelle we're told that the
vice president was in the room in the
Oval Office when that call took place
and you can only imagine what kinds of
emotions were expressed on that phone
call we know that President Biden has
been monitoring this exchange all
morning long here at the White House and
we can also tell you that he personally
signed the commutation Victor boot's
sentence within the past week which
paved the way for this morning's Swap
and now this deal appears to have come
together quite quickly within the past
two weeks according to our reporting
because as recently as the end of
November the state department was still
blasting the Kremlin for a failure to
bargain in good faith over the summer
White House officials repeatedly told us
that they had made an offer for a
prisoner swap but that they were getting
no response now that's not the type of
thing that they usually reveal publicly
but in this case they said they felt
they had no choice but to up the public
pressure because they were getting radio
Silence from the Russians rittner's
return Reiner's return for boot is the
Biden administration's second prisoner
swap with Russia back in April they
swapped Marine veteran Trevor Reed for a
Russian who had been convicted of
smuggling cocaine at the time the U.S
used flight tracking services to make
sure that the prisoner exchange was
taking place as planned and that's
something they may have used today again
during the exchange of Griner who was
coming from Russia and boot coming from
the United States now we don't know
exactly where Reiner's plane is going to
be headed next but we do know that the
eventual destination of course is here
in the U.S
all right Nancy thank you so much you
know we had the interview with shirelle
Griner who is Brittany's wife a couple
of months ago and she was saying that
she had spoken to her on the phone and
she was so worried about her mental
health that Brittany Greiner was very
worried that she might have been
forgotten in this country and certainly
that has not been the case people have
been working on it and I can't only
imagine I'd reached out to cherelle last
week when we knew that this was
happening of course she's not saying
anything nobody wanted to do anything
that would jeopardize this day and now
that it is here I remember you sitting
down with her and asking you does she
have hope and you said that's all she
can yes have hope but you said there was
some despair yes um that she had in her
eyes because she just did not know now
she has the answers that we've all been
waiting for which is Brittany is coming
home yeah we want to see that plane land
safely also eager for news on her health
I mean Brittany was in the right Colony
for multiple weeks the conditions that
are refuted to be very bad right so we
shall see the labor the nutrition even
her mental health yeah and it's been a
year right almost it's been yeah I can
barely speak I'm so excited about this
news today senior investigative
correspondent that's Catherine Heritage
has covered this story since it began
Catherine Brittany Greiner as we know is
not going to go home immediately we know
that she has to go to a hospital first
can you walk us through the process
about what will happen to her now what
are the steps well Gail good morning
this is really the beginning of a
journey for Brittany Griner and her
family and while every case is unique it
comes down to a three-phase process
first as you and Margaret mentioned a
medical and mental health evaluation
second what intelligence officials refer
to as a strategic debriefing this
generally involves the intelligence
agencies as well as law enforcement to
understand every element of Brittany
greiner's detention also the conditions
and more specifically whether the
Russians sought to obtain intelligence
or information from her and finally
reintegration many hostages I've spoken
to discuss how there can be this sense
of sensory overload after their
captivity and the challenges of
reuniting with their family after an
experience where they feel they become a
changed person
Catherine you uh recently spoke to some
of the federal agents who were involved
in the apprehension of Victor boot these
are complicated trade-offs uh High
diplomatic discussions but I am curious
what did those agents tell you about
this man Victor boot who is now free and
going back to Russia
well former DEA agents that were
directly involved in this Global Manhunt
for Victor boot told us that they've
always seen him as a major threat to U.S
national security because he was an arms
dealer with global reach because of his
deep Russian connections he was someone
who was willing to sell arms to drug
cartels to designated terrorist groups
and individuals with the intent and the
capability of harming U.S Americans and
officials in addition what we heard from
these former agents is that it was a
Herculean effort to capture boot across
three continents in 2008 in Thailand he
was eventually extradited to the United
States where he was convicted of charges
including conspiring to kill Americans
and finally they told us they want to
see the families reunited but they had
deep concerns about any potential trade
with Victor boot because of the message
they felt it would say and that it made
good business sense to Target Americans
it's understandable uh Catherine thank
you very much appreciate that we're
going to bring in now CBS News foreign
policy and National Security contributor
H.R McMaster a retired army lieutenant
general and he's also National Security
advisor under President Trump General
good morning to you uh we just talked a
little bit there with Catherine about
how complicated these trade-offs are a
huge day very significant uh prisoner
swamp one of the most significant of the
bite Administration arguably one of the
most significant America has undertaken
going all the way back to the 1960s I
think we should start just with your
reaction to it
hey good morning Tony well yeah I shall
share your sentiment Miguel articulated
there about how happy we are uh the
Britney griner's back and of course what
we're dealing with is a criminal State
all right we know that Vladimir Putin
not only arbitrarily uh detains uh
innocent people for political leverage
but he also commits murder of
individuals and mass murder in what
we're seeing in in uh in Ukraine and and
what was on Syria and chechnya from from
this criminal state but I think what's
really important to note is that a lot
of people have been working on this for
a long time and I think it's uh it's
important to recognize that the by
Administration prioritized you know
getting Brittany Greiner back uh they've
also prioritized getting others out like
Trevor Reed and I think uh this was an
important duty for every Administration
I remember when Aya
um hijazi was was released under the
Trump Administration or chaplain Brunson
from Turkey now those were from
ostensible you know partner States uh
but it's even tougher you know to get
people out of Russia and and uh I'll
tell you Tony it's also important for us
keep in mind those who are left behind
I'm sure that this is what Brittany
Greiner will make this point as well
this is Paul Whalen and and uh Mark
Fogle for example Who Remain uh
unlawfully detained in Russia
all right we're thinking about them also
today as happy as we are for Brittany
Greiner no one is absolutely two other
Americans who are there absolutely uh
General McMaster thank you very much we
appreciate your perspective on all this
but uh we want to emphasize it is a
great day President Biden expected to
speak soon we will of course bring you
that uh live when it happens if it
happens during our show and our coverage
of Brittney griner's release will
continue on CBS News streaming and also
your local news and of course as normal
we have much more news ahead on CBS
mornings this has been a CBS News
special report I'm Tonya decopo with
Gail King and Nate Burleson CBS News New
York
foreign